I got a lot of positive feedback on
investing your money in the SME 500
rather than the S P 500 because when
you're starting out a thousand dollars a
month or two thousand dollars a month
although that's a lot of money for many
people you'd be better served taking
that money and increasing your capacity
to make money and so rather than putting
a thousand dollars in hoping that it's
going to get you eight percent so you're
gonna get eighty dollars at the end of
the year take the thousand dollars to be
able to learn a skill that might be able
to pay you an extra twenty thousand
dollars a year and early on that
discrepancy between what you can put in
and what you can get out is unmatched
anywhere in the market